[Music]
[Applause]
close your eyes and you just might think
you're listening to a grown-up
professional opera singer but no that's
nine-year-old victory brinker and she
just brought the house down on tuesday's
america's got talent it was amazing
victory totally slayed with a stunning
rendition of costa diva during the
second night of the quarterfinals
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she's nine people
nine
[Applause]
yeah and the judges were 10 out of 10
here for it beautiful young girl she's
going to be a superstar simon cowell
predicted that the future is bright for
victory i'm going to make a prediction
you are going to be one of the biggest
stars to emerge from one of these shows
and heidi klum said what we're all
thinking you really you do have the most
amazing gift it almost sounds like it's
not real it almost sounds like it's not
coming from you i would say like you are
the cherry on top of an amazing night
tonight and following the show they
gushed over her performance during a
chat with e.t victory brinker by far
she's absolutely incredible my favorite
of the night
i might have to say that it was
victory the opera singer victory who i
thought was outstanding you know that
singer at the end she's a lot like nine
years old or something it was amazing
fans will find out if victory moves on
to the next round during wednesday's
show but let's flash back to when we
first met the pennsylvania native in
july when i'm singing it makes me feel
happy do you think you can win the whole
thing
yes yeah that's the goal to get four
guesses you want four yeses yeah well
she got four yeses and then some
[Music]
at the time she made agt history after
singing juliet's waltz receiving the
first ever collective golden buzzer we
are all going to give you something
special
five
four
three
two
one
and
sobbing but my favorite part of the
whole thing was the look on all four
judges faces when she started singing
[Music]
[Applause]
before they gave her the golden buzzer
and after they picked their chins up off
the floor they gave victory a whole lot
of love i was not expecting that and
you're angelic
and i loved it i loved it
i loved it too you have a beautiful
voice it was incredible you are
incredible thank you
i agree
you are a star back to the quarterfinals
not only did the judges love it but the
audience did too giving the young singer
a standing ovation so let's just enjoy
victory's tremendous talent one more
time
[Applause]
[Music]